the Joe Rogan experience how difficult
is it to get intelligence on what
they're up to and and what what they're
planning what they're responsible for
like when when you're here in America I
mean how do we do it like yeah who's
over there like how do they do that how
do they find out exactly what these guys
were up to well a lot of its old-school
human human intelligence right so
through sources and a lot of that
sourcing comes from our allies so
whether it's the Israelis or the
Jordanians or the Saudis are whomever so
they know someone who's on the inside or
like how does it work they've got a
source they've got some recruited asset
you know Iran's always been a tough
target for us just like North Korea's a
tough target and so we rely heavily on
our liaison partners and but often times
no matter how good your signals
intelligence is right no mad at
gathering second or photo interpretation
of overhead imagery it's still to this
day no matter how good technology gets
you can't beat having an asset having a
human who's sitting in a meeting
somewhere and then for whatever their
motivation is whatever their you know
reason for doing it they're cooperating
with you or our liaison partners and
they're saying well here's what happened
or here's how that person looked right I
mean maybe you get signals intelligence
because you're picking up you know
communications and then what do you got
you got something on piece of paper and
you're reading a transcript of a meeting
but if you've got somebody who's in that
meeting and you can tell you what people
looked like or what the actual
atmosphere was or the mood or the way
that I mean that's invaluable right and
so we rely a great deal on that but you
basically your Hoover up everything you
can from all the various different types
of intelligence capabilities but it's
it's a it's a tough target I mean
there's no doubt about it I mean that's
why this whole nuclear weapons program
with Iran has always been so difficult
right I mean and you talk to people they
go well they've got about a I've got
about a 12-month breakout time before
they'd have a nuclear weapon and then
other people say well I think they got
about a three-month breakout time well
when you're talking about how long it's
gonna take them they have a nuclear
weapon you'd like to get that there
those parameters a little closer
together right so that you're not having
a complete guess but
it's tough and you know we we spend a
lot of time working on that but I would
would say that we have tremendous allies
in that region and you know I know the
people it's fashionable nowadays to say
well the Trump administration we've been
you know pushing away our allies and
they don't want to work with us and you
know what they do in a part because
again it's the same old story
it's in their best interest all right so
is there any benefit to having someone
like Trump who's very difficult to to
read because he's what you know he's
he's the kind of guy like when when back
daddy was killed he said he died like a
dog like he says crazy [ __ ] and he and
he talks about like with Iran that he
was that they might respond back with
disproportionate results or with a
disproportionate response in comparison
to the the initial attack the cultural
sites the 52 cultural sites but that was
so crazy like to to represent the 52
people that were kidnapped in the
[ __ ] Carter Administration yeah well
yeah we don't really need to go with the
symbolism fellas we could just just pick
some targets but let's not pick the
cultural sites yeah that's you know yeah
those are historic yeah well you know
what that's that's where I say look I
understand why people you know oh my god
you know and yeah yeah but at the same
time that doesn't mean you can't like
you know policies that are in place so I
always put that out there oh I see I get
it that's that's ridiculous right and
it's a self-inflicted wound and you
could argue that you know that most of
the problems they deal with out of this
White House our self-inflicted wounds
because there's a lack of discipline and
so it'd be nice if the president was
more buttoned up of course that's not
gonna be the way it works he he he I
think I'd what do I know but he firmly
believes I think that this is why he got
elected I think that thing it is why he
got elected really yeah I think a lot of
why he got elected is because he's wild
and people like it they like it they're
like something different they're tired
of these people that sound like
politicians you know you hear you know
pick a person Elizabeth Warren you hear
them talk and you feel the [ __ ]
coming out of their mouth while they're
talking you know that they're playing a
role you know that they're with Trump he
might be arrogant he might be crazy he
might be ridiculous
but that's him that's that guy I bet if
you around him all day long he's like
that I mean that's the that's the thing
that people one of the things that
people like about him he's like that all
the time that's that's who he is yeah
he's not boy he doesn't need to [ __ ]
he's Donald Trump he's the [ __ ] multi
billionaire who is now the President of
the United States so it's like he
doesn't feel the need to put on an act
for anybody so when he comes out and
says he died like a dog like that's
that's how he would talk yeah yeah no I
think the consistency I think you're
right there is there's an element of
look I'm tired I am tired of the
[ __ ] I mean I see what you're saying
but I guess what I think then is I mean
what are the chances that you get the
twenty twelve more in 2020 look at that
but we get down to November to the
election and people are just exhausted
by it so they wanted something different
now they've had it are they gonna get to
this point November and get ready to
vote and think I can't take another four
years of it even though it's
entertaining I'm exhausted
people don't like change they get scared
to change and if things are going well
economically and if you know if if it
turns out that this thing with Iran
doesn't turn into anything disastrous by
the time November rolls around I think
he's gonna win in a landslide I really I
don't see unless Bernie Sanders and
Tulsi Gabbard get together and then
everybody goes you know what that would
work like this is this is a real
combination of people that I could I
could get behind unless it's something
like that where there's like some
overwhelming candidate but I don't see
that idaite and they seem to be pushing
for Elizabeth Warren I don't see that
yeah she was a Republican most of her
career and then she became a Democrat
like when she was in her late 40s I find
maybe it's just me but but you know I
don't see a consistent policy message
there I don't see I don't see that
happening for for her this go-around
maybe maybe it'll change maybe you need
I don't know but problem is I feel like
these people just want to be President I
feel like it's a self aggrandizement
thing they just want to be President I
think you could argue that about anybody
in politics so you could you can say
that I mean you know you've met that
person right it was in politics now who
started out by being ahead of the
Republican or Democratic Club in high
school that's all they want to do it and
they're a state senator and then they
say Oh am I gonna run for Congress and
you think what what the [ __ ]
I mean how it's gotta be something you
know yeah the wirings off a little bit
yeah that's the problem right anybody
that wants to be president you wouldn't
want to be President
well I mean I think if you if you look
at if you look at who they've got on the
other side all right I mean I I thought
for a while that well maybe the
Republicans are gonna primary trump
right and then I realized that's a
crazy-ass idea no one's ever gonna do
that no one's gonna get in there and go
again stir it up with him for a primary
yeah it's yellow there's no one that
stands out like you would need someone
that already stands out I mean here we
are in January you would need someone
that already stands out we're talking
about doing 10 months from now you need
someone that's already in the public eye
you can't just jump to the head of the
line like that nobody especially from
the Republican side if he if you say he
wins he get in 2025 four years I'd say
one person I would I would love to see
jump in I don't think she'd ever do it
but would be Condoleezza Rice and just
super smart good person you know
terrific
I don't know but again I don't think
that's gonna I don't think it's gonna
happen I don't know the weave do you
think she would run for president I mean
I would like to think so I doubted it
she hasn't shown any interest in I think
she's enjoying private life too much
yeah and all the [ __ ] she's smart yeah
yeah rack warned every spell like can't
take that stick it up your ass I'm gonna
hang out in my ranch or whatever the
[ __ ] she's got nobody comes out of
Republican administration he's gotta
have a ranch get a ranch somewhere you
lay low
[Applause]